hallöchen meine lieben Freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge
Minecraft free ich habe mir gedacht jo
Luca nimm mal wieder eine weitere Folge
auf weil ja heute ist der 3 im Dezember
und da dachte ich mir okay das ist ganz
chillig wo bist du wo bist du wo bist du
bist wasst du denn hier ich bin hab den
Server
gehackt
alles Server ich ma alles kaputt Alter
alles kaputt Hallo und deswegen würde
ich sagen wir begrüßen den sturmwaffel
in der Minecraft freeze Welt es wurde
zwar noch nicht so krass in den
Kommentaren gewünscht dass die Welt zu
Multiplayer freigegeben wird allerdings
hatte der Sturm für mich angeschrieben
und meinte so hey wie wä es denn wenn
wir eventuell das Minecraft freeze
Projekt von dir so ein bisschen mit paar
anderen Youtuber machen das heißt ich
nehme jetzt die erste Folge mit
sturmwfel auf unter anderem dabei sind
auch noch
pixelwolf rotpilz krancrafter hallo K
Petr und noch ein paar andere und wir
spielen das ganze jetzt online und
weiter erzählst du mal genau wir haben
uns bzw ich habe deine Folgen gesehen
und fand die echt schön fand dieses
Projekt echt schön besonders weil es mal
wieder so ein bisschen back to the roots
gechillt ist ich werde auch mal nebenbei
einfach ein bisschen anfangen abzubauen
ich lasse mich hier mal neben dir
niederch das ja und F fand die Idee
dahinter einfach so klasse und dachte
mir dann e schreib Cony mal an denn
gerade jetzt so so in der Weihnachtszeit
yay ich habe W gegettet ne das ist eben
eben dachte ich mir immer ein schönes
Projekt jetzt gerade für die
Weihnachtszeit dass wir im Prinzip eben
mit den Leuten die bis datu mitmachen
eben so ein kleines Städtchen bauen wie
wir das genau noch limitieren ist ja bei
uns noch recht offen gesehen
sie also wie wir das machen dit mit dem
end Zeitpunkt den es soll ja schon so
ein so ein weihnachtsadvent ein Advent
Event sozusagen werden weißt du ein
Advent Event oh der hau ja die
wortspieler raus du nee also wir dachten
uns halt ihr kennt wahrscheinlich alle
so so craftattack mehr oder weniger und
da ist es halt auch so in dem Projekt
dass die Leute da nicht viele Regeln am
Start haben dass man zocken kann wie man
möchte man kann aufnehmen Tags man kann
aufnehmen nachts so nach man kann Nudel
machen warm man kann Nudel machen Kal
Alter jedenfalls hab uns angedacht so so
ein Projekt ohne Regeln wä vielleicht
ganz witzig so ganz chillig also es ist
jetzt nicht so dass jemand ankommt und
meint ich bau hier eine riesige
steinfirma hin oder so sondern es soll
halt schon so sein da baut dann wer ein
lu dann baut wer dies dann baut wer das
und das wird bestimmt ganz chillig
apropos ich hle mir da hinten mal ein
bisschen Eis und es gibt halt quasi
nahzu keine Regeln man kann am Tag davon
so eine Folge einfach mal hochladen und
wie kann ich eigentlich Eis
abbauen mit so einer silk Kacke hier
damit das nicht kaputt geht das gerade
aufgefallen oder du gehst in eisbiom und
lässt Wasser schmz stellen wo
du alter
niemals weiß ich aber tatsächlich finde
ich so ein bisschen so ein bisschen
Grauzone ah Gott ey ich bin ich brauche
Essen ich habe Essen für dich bisschen
ja ich habe mir mir gerade schon zwei
gemacht ach so du kannst dich übrigens
auch das ist natürlich ein
gemeinschaftliches Projekt ich habe bei
mir in der Kiste habe ich ein bisschen
Kohle da kannst du dich auch dran
bedienen haben wir eigentlich irgendwas
vergessen wir haben auch gerade einfach
so spontan drauf los nee also also es
ist halt genau wie gesagt in dem Stile
also craftattack 2 läuft ja z.B auch
noch das soll wie gesagt keine
Konkurrenzveranstaltung mal ganz kurz
Beton zu irgendwelchen anderen Projekten
laufen sein aber zu oder nee auf keinen
Fall auf keinen Fall ich meine wir
gucken ja selber alle noch total
angespannt aber es geht halt einfach
auch darum
das ist ja so für uns auch ein bisschen
dieses adventsfeeling und ich finde das
auch schön gerade dadurch dass ich z.B
mein Weihnachtskalender z.B gekippt
wurde das habe ich vielen Leuten schon
im Stream gesagt
dass
dass ich das halt nicht machen konnte
weil ich da halt ein paar Probleme
bekommen hab tatsächlich
ist das jetzt halt eine tolle
Möglichkeit finde ich über diesen Advent
auch mal mit Leuten mit mit dem man
sonst auch nur schwer wieder was macht
weißt du ja klar eben eben diese Chance
warahrzunehmen einfach mal ein bisschen
bisschen entspannt wieder beisammen zu
sein so das vermiss ich so ein bisschen
immer dieses PvP Action auf die Fresse
hauen ist
cool bestimmt für für ab und an immer
mal so zwischendurch und das mache ich
auch gerne aber ich will einfach auch
mal mit Luca irgendwie gechillt ein paar
Fragen z.B beantworten und einfach
irgendwie so eine kleine Stadt machen
und dann am Ende ja haben wir auch
gesagt ist Map Download und da könnt ihr
durch das kleine dass das adventsdorf
2014 durchgehen tatsächlich in diesem
freeze Projekt kommt dann das kleine
Youtuber adventsdorf im Prinzip raus ja
also wir hoffen dass letztendlich am
Ende irgendwie so ein kleines cooles
Dorf zusammenbaut wo dann zusammen
rauskommt wo dann einer irgendwie ein lu
gebaut hat wie ich das vorhin schon
gesagt habe einer
eisschlittschuhlaufbahn der andere so
winterstand und das ist denke ich ganz
cool weil ich mag an Weihnachten gerade
diese Weihnachtsmärkte einfach wo man
nachher Uni oder nachher Schule oder was
weiß ich einfach hingehen kann und dann
sich einfach irgendwie glü
kann woll ich nicht sagen nein aber ich
mag das irgendwie das ist eigentlich
ganz cool deswegen B ich auch schon so
eine Hütte die einfach überhaupt nicht
wie Weihnachten
aussieht so so also ich meine das wird
ja alles dann so gemeinschaftlich ne so
ein Town Square da kann man sich treffel
schlit laufen mit KF ja allerdings muss
ich schon schon am Anfang sagen dass ich
ab dem 19 weg bin das heißt wir hatten
natürlich gedacht
am ja ne was ich jetzt gesagt okay okay
gut gut mehr für euch ma mir ein
bisschen
Fläche dann ich mir gleich ein Bett ein
kleines gutes Bett verstehst das ist ja
sehr sehr weihnachtlich nein nein ein
ein Beet
einke ich unglaublich gerne an ich habe
noch Samen für dich falls du das oh ja
gib mir deine Samen
lasasel du h schon
wieder ich hab so viele Erfolge ja
jedfalls hab wir deswegen gedacht dass
wir das ganz mal für Multiplayer
aufmachchenil wenn ich alleine hier baue
dann kommt h wahrscheinlich nie
irgendwas cooles bei raus und meistens
wird's dann auch na ja nicht sonderlich
weihnachtlich und das sieht nicht cool
aus und das habe ich auch alles schon
gesagt deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich
hole mir ein bisschen Hilfe mit dazu und
Menschen ja deswegen sind die and jetzt
hier auch mit im
Projekt und ihr könnt uns übrigens auf
Twitter unter dem hashagfeze am Anfang
war der fragla aber wir hab jetzt
gedacht okay da so viele dabei sind
ändern wir den Hashtag zu #fze könnt ihr
uns einfach Fragen stellen und da habe
ich auch schon wieder Fragen rausgesucht
für diese Folge und ich würde sagen wir
fangen an mit der Frage von juls buulsi
sie
fragt an Weihnachten irgendetwas
bestimmtes oder gibt's da so immer das
gleiche also ob du jetzt sagst okay an
Weihnachten gibt jedes Jahr bei uns
Chicken McNuggets von McDonald's die
gibt sonst nie und da muss man einfach
zuulangen so nach
dem ja natürlich bei uns gibt immer die
saftigen
chicken ne bei uns gibt immer Rose beef
tatsächlich ehrlich hab so eine Speise
die immer ja immer jedes Jahr Rose beef
oder obwohl zu Heiligabend gibt's immer
V machen wir dann immer so einmal Fett
und am nächsten Tag ist dann so
Familientag da kommt die ganze Familie
dann zusammen und dann ist so R
tatsächlich ist immer das wod drauf sich
alle freuen und verschmähen okay krass
hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht also
bei uns ich kenne das auch nicht
irgendwie von anderen Familien das ist
jetzt bei dir ich ma mal so so so eine
coole W pp hier nach unten also dass man
nicht so Strip Gang hat sondern
irgendwie so eine zwei breite
Wendeltreppe ich versuche mich da mal
einfach dran Schaufel kaputt geht nicht
mehr also bei uns es erfolgreich
an so richtig richtig entmutigend so ja
ich mach das jetzt schel ach ne keine
Lust
mehr also ich kenne das ehrlich gesagt
nicht dass man immer das Gleiche zu
Weihnachten hat wir haben nämlich immer
was anderes also wir hatten jetzt
letztes Jahr hatten wir so Curry und
Fleisch und ganz viel Kroketten und
Salat und alles und jetzt dieses J
fahren wir halt z.B nach Österreich in
Hotel und was da kommt weiß ich nicht
dann noch einfach ja auf jeden diese
saftigen chick
McNuggets nee also wir haben irgendwie
immer was anderes und ich freue mich
auch nicht immer so jedes Jahr wenn ich
mir denke oh Weihnachten geil Rose beef
oh ich habe eine Höhle gefunden nee also
da da habe ich tatsächlich Bo du hast
Höhle das ist gut
bra eisenisen hier ist direkt Eisen ja
deswegen ich hab gerade nur gesehen ich
bin richtig heiß jetzt gerade renn wie
ein aufgeregtes Kind hin und her ja ich
merk schon aber ich bau gerade schon ab
oder Bau du es einfach ab oder bist du
in meinem tollen Gang ich nehme mal drei
Eisen mit damit ich mir ich nehme drei
Eisen mit damit ich mir so so Dings
machen
kann ein okay
mitgenommen das gut fast das gleiche wie
dre ich kann aber für dich noch was
mitnehmen okay oh junge hier kriegt eine
Spinne an der Decke hier ist ein Zombie
was ist denn los wie gesagt das wird ein
ruhiges Projektchen ja so zack zack zack
einmal so gechillt also ich find es halt
schön für die Weihnachtstage also liebe
varo ab göttisch aber nebenbei irgendwie
so ein bisschen rumgeplenkelt Z zur
Weihnachtszeit finde ich auch echt schön
mus ich sagen
ja die zweite Frage ist von Z Player D
und zwar schreibt der #feze was war für
euch die am weihnachtlichsten
geschmückteste Stadt Deutschland die ihr
je gesehen habt
oh
Gott die am Wein oh Gott in
Deutschland wie Deutschland woh nicht
Kosovo oder was nee ich habe ich habe
überhaupt keine Ahnung hast du dein
favorite ich habe bin bei
sowas also no Plan Ros ich muss sagen
ich war vor zwei
Jahren
in wo war das ich glaube in Leipzig auf
dem Weihnachtsmarkt und der war bisher
so der Junge du gibst aber hier Gas
NES ich bin ich bin richtig am viechen
gerade also ich war füror zwei Jahren
bei in bei bei
Leipzig auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt da ja
und der hat mir eigentlich echt ganz gut
gefallen muss ich sagen aber sonst habe
ich jetzt auch kein favorite ich meine
alle Weihnachtsmärkte sind mehr oder
weniger schön ich sehe da auch nie sehr
große Unterschiede okay die Höhle ist zu
Ende erkundet wie viel Eisen hast du ich
konnte nicht alles mitnehmen aber ich
habe
aber hier ist auch noch was guck ST komm
komm hier ist noch was und da hinten in
der Ecke ist auch noch zi zack Z besten
noch Kohle mit oder irgendwie so hier
geht übrigens auch noch weiter in andere
Gänge da sehe ich schon ist fantastisch
das ist fantastisch immer gut das heißt
näm ich immer Liebe Fledermäuse ja
Fledermäuse stehen immer sind Zeichen
der Liebe auf jeden Fall also du hast
kein favorite bei
den nee tatsächlich nicht also ich war
bin aber Weihnachtsmarkt technisch bis
Datum meinem Leben auch noch nicht so
rumgekommen liegt vielleicht auch daran
okay wollen wir vielleicht pennen es es
dunkel ja oben ne warte ich komme ich
komme mal wieder hoch dann konzentrieren
wir uns schon mal auf die nächste Frage
und zwar schreibt Lisa Marie ottopal was
schenkst du deinen Geschwistern so zu
Weihnachten wenn du welche hast also ich
beantworte dir jetzt erstmal und zwar
meiner Schwester weiß ich noch gar nicht
was ich schenken soll weil ich finde das
ist mal richtig schwer so
puupertierenden Mädchen also die ist
halt 15 oder 16 irgendwas zu Weihnachten
zu schenken weil ich nicht weiß was ich
den schenken soll also meiner Mutter
wollte ich das Sascha Album dieses
winteralbum von Sasa schenken aber meine
Schwester keine Ahnung weiß ich echt
noch nicht vielleicht könnt ihr mal in
die Kommentare schreiben was ihr euch
als 15jähriges Mädchen wünschen würdet
was sagst du yay Meinungsbild ich liege
im Bett ja ich habe
keins du hast keins nein ich bin auch
gerade hierfgekommen auf den serverte
ich zwei Wolle und zwei Fäden drei Fäden
hast du noch ein Faden nein
verdammt Schalter dann einem Faden Alter
egal egal alles gut da sind Skelette mit
Weihnachtsmützen auf sie mit gebrill man
nennt mich auch den XX to Nation der
Free Seen okay junge wie viel achevs du
einfach packst Alter guck mal egal was
der macht in diesem Projekt immer zu den
Waffen technischer Fortschritt
Monsterjäger fang an zu ackern junge
alles Alter der ganze Chat ist voll bei
mir mit deinen Achievements ja das
richtig so soll so sein ich habe auch
schon fast drei Level al ich hab willst
ein Schwertkampf willst sch sterben
laiches Projekt oder
varo varo 3 hier
genau Trainingslager ins geheim
eigentlich h ist spinne ich Hool mal
eben bisschen Seide und dann kannst du
den Bett machen braucht man tatsächlich
nur drei vier Seite brauchst du hier
mcraft mit kkraftter genau
nächste Frage beantwortest du jetzt mal
wieder als erstes und zwar ist es
schwierig das war die Frage die ich vor
meinte die eigentlich nichts mit
Weihnachten zu tun hat aber eventuell
ganz interessant für den ein oder
anderen ist und zwar ist es
schwierig Youtube unter einen Hut zu
kriegen wenn man nebenbei noch studiert
also nimmt das Studium ein so viel Zeit
dass man keine Zeit mehr für youtube hat
ja nicht nur nicht nur Youtube also es
kommen ja viele Sachen zusammen
tatsächlich also die meiner Meinung nach
immer ziemlich anstrengend sind dann
also sei es denn einfach nur mal wenn
man alleine wohnt und ich glaube du
hatest es auch mal thematisiert danke
dir ähm ich niste mich mal kurz noch mal
hier ein mit dem Bett also sei es denn
alleine oh ich habe
Erfolg nee also sei es denn alleine
irgendwie einkaufen und Wohnung sauber
halten und Freunde irgendwie noch unter
den Hut kriegen und alles weißt du das
sind so so Aspekte die die sind ja sehr
alltäglich für viele aber wenn man dann
so ich meine du machst ja momentan auch
zwei Videos täglich wenn man dann
tatsächlich mal vielleicht auch sich
dahin hockt und dann für
whatever so so so an die an die
vier vier Stunden 5 Stunden da sich
hinhockt dann ist halt schon viel Zeit
des Tages halt auch weg ne das ist
tatsächlich das was was mir immer ein
bisschen zusetzt das ist halt echt
hartes Time Management ist ja also bei
mir ist es jetzt auch gerade so z.B
jetzt heute ist es 11 Uhr abends und ich
muss morgen früh in eine Uni und ich
muss jetzt noch das Video hier
bearbeiten und hochladen weil ich
einfach morgen früh von 9R bis abends 19
Uni hab danach wollten wir alle mit
Freunden halt so auf Weihnachts Markt
was halt zwar eine Freizeitaktivität ist
aber was man ja irgendwie auch noch mal
unterbringen muss weil wenn man nie was
mit Freunden machen
würde hätte man keine Freunde das ist ja
gut dass du das erkannt hast ja kommt
spät in meinem Leben die Erkenntnis
jetzt habe ich auch keine Freunde mehr
aber das dat warz
schön ja also keine Ahnung das muss man
halt auch noch irgendwie alles machen es
ist recht schwer aber ich denke wenn man
sich zusammenreiß und ein
disziplinierter Mensch ist dann schaff
man das also man braucht jetzt nicht
sagen ich will nicht Youtube machen weil
ich studiere und alles also das ist
natürlich Schwachsinn man kriegt das
immer unter ein Hut ich meine ja wenn
man alles ist machbar wenn man es möchte
Punkt auf Ende Bast ja genau mehr
braucht man da glaub ich auch nicht echt
nicht sagen ich suche die ganze Zeit
noch diese winterlichen Bäume hast du
eventuell Knochen dass ich das mal eben
hier anpflanzen könnte Gott manchmal
manchmal störter deine leidung so ein
bisschen ja ich weiß auch nicht woran
das liegt vielleicht hat die Telekom
wieder so ein paar
einbuen wollte es ein bisschen
dramatischer machen jetzt aber ich GLB
das bei weit nicht so dramatisch hab ich
wieder gehäng gehangen geh nee ne nee
nee ne nee also jetzt gerade nur aber
jetzt ist alles gut so Mincraft FS mit
concrafter wie weit kann man an dem
Wasser das Feld bauen
Ding weißt was ich meine weiß was ich
meine drei drei Felder vom Wasser weg
oder oder okay nicht vier sicher ja drei
Felder also Wasser 1 2
3 schau dir Folge 27 von mir an vol e e
dass dass du das no so weißt ist krass
nein Spaß als ob das 2 war
m der totale Peter Ludolf Alter schon
dein nudelcheiß
rausgehauen jetzt s ich du hast es
richtig drauf und mach ein auf guck dir
folge7 an das B auch hier das stimmt gar
nicht das stimmt gar nicht das vierte
bleibt auch hey das vierte kann ja das
wird aber nacher Zeit geht das erst
kaputt Minecraft Folge
28al jedenfalls letzte Frage für heute
weil wir auch schon recht
ähau weit sind hier bist Du früher eher
oft oder eher nicht so oft mit dem
Schnitten fahren gegangen fragt Shadow
Arts also bist du eher so der Skifahrer
oder bist eher der schätenfahrer weiß
ich bin eigentlich so der der fällt
immer den den der sturmwaffe fällt
einfach immer den Berg runter das stimmt
gar nicht bin
Snowboarder die bis ich mir die Nase
gebrochen habe das hattest Du im
Livestream gesagt ne Vlog Video was mir
angeschaut hab guck mal Luca guck meine
videosazing
fabulous ma jetzt hier echt so ganz süß
ich glaube ich ma hier die die bürke
oder so nehme ich für mein Haus so ein
bisschen Lollipop aus so wie ich fang
mit dem texack sieht ein bisschen cool
aus Birk neack istatslich echt schön ja
wir hat nämlich so ein paar Regel
natürlich am Anfang festgelegt und zw
das unter anderem auch dass jeder dieses
tpack benutzen sollte weil hier wo wir
uns jetzt hingebaut haben sieht es nur
cool aus wenn man dieses Tack
hattim du es ist aber auch schon weit
drin ne immer
folgenlänge es ist auf jeden Fall schon
bei 18 Minuten oder 18 Minuten genau
aber ich möchte immer so viel erreichen
und dann denk ich mir so ich möchte
jetzt die Wendeltreppe machen und das
und dies und dies und
und jenes und und deswegen würde ich
sagen ich bin jetzt mittlerweile soweit
dass das Häuschen so so ein bisschen
aussieht da kommt natürlich nach noch
Schnee dran das wird noch alles
weihnachtlich Freunde sturmel Haus sieht
so aus wie ihr es da hinten halt seht
danke danke sehr nett holzstumpf hallo
ich bin ich bin eine Folge hier ein 2 3
1 Z gut ich würde auf jeden Fall sagen
von meiner Folge was wir sehen uns in
der nächsten Folge morgen wieder wenn
euch es gefallen hat dann zeigt uns mit
einer Bewertung und Fragen auf Twitter
unter dem #feze und dann BS zum nächsten
Mal tschüss ciao